bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le 7 8
sport votre émission fait sa rentrée
c'est parti pour une nouvelle saison
avec de nouveaux consultants qui
apporteront toute leur analyse tout au
long de cette nouvelle saison mais tout
d'abord place au sommaire de ce 8
septembre
notez bien ces dates sur votre agenda du
18 au 22 février 2015 le vélodrome de 50
ans en Yvelines accueille les mondiaux
de cyclisme sur piste cet homme est
désormais vice-champion du Monde
d'aviron le versaillais Thomas Barouk
vient de remporter sa première médaille
mondiale il revient pour le 7 8 sport
sur cette performance exceptionnelle
dans quelques heures les féminines
d'Élancourt vont faire leur grand début
en ProA de tennis de table si le
maintien sera une mission délicate des
championnes de France de Pro B
trépignent d'impatience à l'idée de se
confronter au poids lourds de l'élite
évidemment comme d'habitude en fin
d'émission l'essentiel des résultats du
week-end mais tout d'abord place à notre
page spéciale cyclisme
je le disais dans les titres l'Union
cycliste international a désigner il y a
tout juste deux semaines 50 ans en
Yvelines et le vélodrome national pour
accueillir les prochains mondiaux sur
piste du 18 au 22 février 2015 quels
sont les enjeux de cette organisation
d'une compétition internationale comment
accueillir un tel mondial les réponses
et les mondes réponse avec nos deux
invités de ce premier set-weets sport de
la saison Michel Laugier à mes côtés
président de la Communauté
d'Agglomération de 50 ans en Yvelines
bonsoir à vous bon merci d'être passé
sur le 7 8 ports et en face de vous
Olivier quégénaire directeur général de
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
bonsoir Olivier merci à tous les deux
d'être là alors tout d'abord une
première réaction à cette attribution
des Mondiaux Michel Laugier tu es très
heureux vraiment parce que c'est
exceptionnel ce qui nous arrive je vous
rappelle quand même que nous avons
inauguré les Vélodrome en début d'année
et là un an après on peut déjà
accueillir les championnats du monde on
en avait rêvé mais dans quelques années
là les choses sont précipitées et on dit
très heureux il faut savoir saisir cette
belle opportunité que l'UCI nous donne
ça veut dire aussi que c'est la
récompense de tout le travail que nous
avons fait au cours des dernières années
ça veut dire aussi que c'est la
récompense de l'implantation sur
Saint-Quentin Yvelines de ce superbe
Vélodrome et ça veut dire aussi que
c'est un vélo Rome qui est reconnu au
plus haut niveau international j'imagine
que c'est le même son de cloche du côté
de la Fédération quand on s'était
rencontré il y a quelques jours pour
préparer un reportage Olivier je vous
demandais si vous avez eu un peu les
mêmes frissons que François Pervis qui
s'est exprimé sur les réseaux sociaux à
l'annonce de cette attribution à la
France pour les Mondiaux 2015 bien sûr à
titre personnel bien sûr mais au nom de
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
c'est un grand un grand honneur que
d'avoir été choisi puisqu'on était dans
un match avec d'autres pays on rappelle
qu'il y avait l'Australie et le Mexique
et qu'au final c'est la France qui a été
désignée à l'intérieur de la France et
la Fédération Française de Cyclisme
basée à Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines qui a
gagné le match face à face à
Aguascalientes donc évidemment on était
très heureux on mesure le travail qui
est préparatoire à cette attribution
donc c'est vrai que de partager ça avec
les élus de la Fédération avec les
salariés de la Fédération et les
sportifs c'est un grand moment on est
toujours dessus qu'un jour après on
reçoit énormément de messages de
félicitations de bonheur de fierté donc
on les apprécie parce que c'est pas tous
les jours et c'est un moment qui est
quand même extrêmement symbolique pour
une fédération que d'organiser très vite
des championnats du monde dans un
équipement top mondial et évidemment
quand on a des élus comme le président
de la de l'agglomération et l'ancien
président de l'agglomération qui porte
ses projets depuis des années en croyant
dans la Fédération et ses sportifs c'est
une vraie marque de soutien et ça fait
extrêmement plaisir avant de poursuivre
je vous propose de
recontelliser un petit peu cette
attribution des Mondiaux nous avons
réalisé un reportage il y a quelques
jours au Vélodrome avec un montage de
Pascal Joseph
pour l'instant les tribunes sont vides
mais dans quelques mois elle pourrait
bien entendre raisonner de nombreuses
marseillaises avec l'attribution par
l'UCI des championnats du monde sur
piste 2015 à la France du 18 au 22
février prochain le vélo drone national
de 50 ans en Yvelines vivra un an à
peine après sa naissance le premier
grand moment de sa jeune vie c'est une
page d'histoire sans fausse modestie
mais quand même quoi organiser en France
un championnat du monde c'est une des
pages de l'histoire d'une fédération qui
est centenaire donc on est des personnes
qui sommes en capacité de porter un
projet comme ça on laissera un moment
donné dans le grand livre d'histoire de
la Fédération cette race c'est fabuleux
l'événement majeur du cyclisme sur piste
retourne en France ne vend après les
Mondiaux de Bordeaux une occasion unique
pour la génération dorée des Pervis
Baugé et Almeida de dominer la planète à
domicile avant les Jeux olympiques de
Rio et dans cette quête l'équipe de
France pourra compter sur le soutien des
5000 personnes que peuvent contenir les
gradins du Vélodrome donc faut vraiment
dire à nos au public français soyez là
derrière vos coureurs ils attendent ça
ils attendent d'être vraiment porté par
leur par leur public pour dire ce
chaudron là il était fabuleux et c'est
le drone national du coup devient une
référence mondiale
au dernier championnat du monde
colombien la France avait décroché
quatre titres dont le triplet historique
de François Pervis et une médaille de
bronze en vitesse par équipe
évidemment une organisation d'un Mondial
à la renommée internationale comme comme
les mondiaux de cyclisme surpiste c'est
synonyme de budget faut pas faut pas
l'éviter cette question la candidature
au début a eu du mal à être validé pour
pour cette raison là c'est synonyme que
tout va bien le budget est bouclé
Olivier c'est en effet une bonne
nouvelle on s'est lancé à partir du
moment où on avait les les feux ouverts
et je crois que comme dans toute
entreprise si on attend d'avoir toutes
les réponses positives on partira jamais
on sentait qu'on avait suffisamment de
de messages positifs et notamment
budgétaire pour dire on y va et le
président l'appartient le président de
la Fédération a pris la décision un
lundi soir donc la veille de la veille
de l'attribution disant bien sûr on est
on est on est favorable et on voit il
avait raison puisqu'on voit derrière la
dynamique que ça a créé donc on est sur
un budget d'un million 700 000 euros TTC
qui est qui est couvert de de
financement public mais également de de
financement privé et puis de bonnes
nouvelles puisque
je vous dis quand on est dans une belle
dynamique comme ça on est contacté par
par des structures par des mécènes qui
nous disent si vous avez besoin peut
vous aider et bien sûr on va aller on va
les recevoir on va discuter avec eux et
c'est un c'est un moment important parce
que on parle de 2015 il faut juste se
rappeler que c'est dans 6 mois donc ça
va très vite on est au mois de septembre
c'est au mois de février donc on a 6
mois et aussi le sel d'un événement
comme ça c'est que ce sera entre le 18
et le 22 et le 23 sera fini donc on
connaît la date il y a un compte à
rebours
je voulais dire c'est que je voudrais
souligner surtout le rôle essentiel du
président de la Fédération Française de
Cyclisme la partie exactement parce que
il m'en a parlé il y a quelques mois
déjà dont il y a quelques mois la
communauté d'agglo avait donné aussi son
accord pour accompagner mais ça avait
été facile donc j'ai essayé aussi à ses
côtés d'ouvrir quelque part et je peux
vous dire aussi que par exemple la
participation de l'État a
négocier à l'Open de Gold de France donc
le peinte de France de Gaulle pardon
donc au début juillet où là le
secrétaire d'État changeait des Sports
s'est engagé et comme ils sont engagés
la région aussi qui était présente m'a
dit nous aussi on sera on sera présent
donc ça a été un travail important mais
il a fallu la personnalité la
détermination du président pour que
cette mondial soit attribuée évidemment
quand un territoire accueille un mondial
quel que soit la discipline ça implique
de nombreuses retombées économiques 50
ans Yvelines va pouvoir bénéficier de
cela déjà toutes les caméras du monde
seront braqués sur 50 ans en Yvelines
donc on a fait ce vélodrome c'est aussi
pour ça deuxièmement ce sont toutes les
retombées on a travaillé quand même
depuis plusieurs années sur tous ceux
qui pouvait arriver autour du Vélodrome
puisqu'on a terminé les travaux de
l'avenue du bas du lac pas plus tard
qu'il y a quelques jours donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes prêts nous
sommes prêts pour accueillir tous les
visiteurs qui vont venir sont en voiture
soit en en commun je crois qu'on va
surtout inciter les étrangers à venir en
transport en commun la gare est prête le
cheminement aujourd'hui jusqu'au
Vélodrome et hyper bien fléchés nous
avons fait les trottoirs qu'il fallait
les pistes cyclables aussi pour aller
jusqu'au Vélodrome donc nous aussi on
est très impliqué et puis surtout ce
sont toutes les retombées 5000 visiteurs
jours ça veut dire aussi que les hôtels
les commerces les restaurants qui sont
tout autour vont aussi pouvoir
bénéficier de cet apport du Mondial et
les hôtels justement il y en aura assez
pour accueillir toutes ces populations
fans de cyclisme il y a quelques
chantiers en cours il y a quelque chose
qui est sauf que là pour le moment vous
savez l'hôtel devant le Vendôme ne sera
pas terminé pour le pôle mondial par
contre nous avons de nombreux hôtels sur
les territoires de Saint-Quentin nous
avons après les jusqu'à Versailles et
puis on peut aller jusqu'à Paris vous
savez en train d'écart 25 minutes de
Paris donc aujourd'hui en tout cas nous
notre premier objectif c'est d'essayer
de bien sensibiliser tous les
partenaires locaux pour que tout le
monde puisse vraiment en profiter je me
retourne du côté d'Olivier qui génère
par rapport aux objectifs sportifs parce
qu'évidemment un mondial ça veut dire
médaille et Marseillaise et podium il y
a eu un excellent bilan à Cali en
Colombie cet hiver comment vous voyez
ces prochains Mondiaux faire mieux
encore je pense notamment à François
Pervis pour François Labarre est très
très haute puisqu'il a déjà trois
médailles mais globalement ce qu'on voit
c'est que les Français vont venir
disputer un mondial chez eux ils
s'entraîne là tous les jours et Michael
d'Almeida en parler dans le reportage en
disant on passe comme 20h par jour dans
ce pardon non par semaine dans le dans
le vélo de Rome donc on parle de la
maison du Vélodrome pour eux c'est
l'endroit de l'entraînement toutes les
conditions sont réunies et là il faut
vraiment féliciter et remercier la
comédie agglomération de 50 ans en
Yvelines parce que quelque part on n'est
pas chez nous c'est pas une propriété de
la fédération mais toutes les tous les
ingrédients sont là pour que les at
parfois au quotidien donc ils sont sur
des bases qu'ils connaissent donc
ensuite évidemment arrive l'objectif un
athlète de cette les athlètes de
l'équipe de France et quelle était là
sont vraiment des des athlètes qui ne
visent qu'un objectif c'est la médaille
et les tensions entre les coureurs ça y
est c'est du passé on a oublié ce qui
s'est passé à Cali oui oui bien sûr
parce que vous savez les tensions sur
pareil vous si vous les prenez
indépendamment du contexte ou de la
compétition vous allez soit les
interpréter soit pas forcément les
comprendre un groupe qui vit ensemble
c'est pas toujours simple pour autant on
a vraiment des Champions et des
champions parce qu'il faut vraiment
associer
c'est un groupe comme extrêmement
talentueux c'est c'est les meilleurs
Français qui sont là c'est notre équipe
de France qui performe et qui se prépare
aussi pour les pour les Jeux Olympiques
donc oui l'objectif c'est d'aller
chercher les médailles chez nous et
vraiment quand vous les interrogez vous
l'avez fait les athlètes sont
extrêmement motivés on avait Thomas
Bouddha qui avait aussi à Cali gagné une
médaille d'or à l'Omnium il a 20 ans
donc on a aussi une nouvelle génération
qui est derrière la barre et et c'est
normal les athlètes ils viennent là pour
gagner ils savent en plus que c'est un
championnat du monde qualificatif pour
les Jeux de Rio les points donc pour la
course la course au point pour les Jeux
Olympiques se passera à 50 ans en
Yvelines et donc le message c'est
vraiment ça au public venez supporter
vos vos athlètes il l'attendent les deux
questions qu'on a aujourd'hui enfin les
deux remarques qu'on a de nos athlètes
de l'équipe de France et une grande
fierté qu'on peut le partager d'avoir
les championnats du monde chez nous et
deuxièmement se dire mais vous pensez
que les les gradins seront plein alors
oui si on a un message à faire passer
venez les venez les encourager parce
qu'il vous attendent et on sait que
c'est quand même un élément de
motivation supplémentaire pour nos
coureurs non pas noté il y aura beaucoup
de monde dans les gradins du Vélodrome
avant de de vous laisser repartir les
Mondiaux évidemment vont intervenir en
pleine période hivernale Michel Laugier
après l'ouverture du Vélodrome il y a
peut-être un autre projet qui est
toujours dans les tuyaux depuis des
années c'est la colline d'Élancourt vous
préparez vos ski tout doucement ou pas
écoutez pour le moment je suis loin de
fertiles mais on travaille sur ce sur ce
projet là le
de la ville et bien sûr favorable à ce
projet maintenant on va pas faire
n'importe quoi donc on doit rencontrer
les investisseurs sur appel que ce
projet là sera financé uniquement par
des fonds privés et donc on doit les
rencontrer pas plus tard que mercredi et
parce que nous avons aussi quelques
principes de base il va falloir aussi
que le projet soit beau intégré dans un
site où il y a des habitants qui sont
pas loin mais en tout cas je crois que
c'est aussi là un beau projet puisque ça
serait la seule piste de ski de
l'Île-de-France et
la décision interviendrait quand à peu
près vous avez un délai déjà en tête que
sur le principe d'avoir un équipement
tel que celui-ci on a commencé à faire
des rayons publiques maintenant quand on
sera d'accord sur le parti pris
architectural sur le fonctionnement sur
le business plan et surtout sur
l'aménagement qui aura autour parce que
là on en parle que du jour que du
ski-dom or ce sera toute la colline qui
devrait être aménagée avec une partie
privée pour que les habitants
d'Élancourt et les cinq trentinois
puissent aussi avoir lieu de balade un
lieu exceptionnel parce que c'est le
plus aussi de la région de France en
tout cas avant l'installation d'une
piste de ski et en cours il y aura des
le 18 février prochain le 18 février
2015 c'est mon duo de cyclisme sur piste
oui mais juste de te rappeler que avant
les championnats du monde
les championnats de France du 2 au 5
octobre prochain évidemment au vélo
merci à tous les deux d'être passé sur
ce 1er 7 eSport de la saison et à
bientôt j'imagine dans les gradins ou
sur la piste du vélodrome dans quelques
heures les féminines d'Élancourt vont
faire leur grand début en proie de
tennis de table si le maintien sera une
mission assez délicate les championne de
France de Pro brépignent d'impatience à
l'idée de se confronter au poids lourd
de l'élite nationale
et l'esprit d'équipe c'est pour moi le
plus important c'est cette force qui
nous permettra de gagner des matchs et
j'ai logiquement trouver ma place ici
pour la première fois de son histoire le
club va évoluer dans l'élite du tennis
de table français seul et vaodorova et
billiana Todorovic connaissent les joues
du championnat de France à 35 ans la
capitaine et l'emportoise entame sa
treizième saison de proah et fait office
de guide
parce que c'est vrai que l'année
dernière par exemple c'était eux qui
m'ont qui vont parler un petit peu de
joueuse de progrès parce que je je l'ai
pas connu et cette saison ce sera ce
sera plutôt moi j'essaie de donner le
conseil je vais essayer leur dire
comment comment ça se passe parce que
c'est un petit peu différent par rapport
le problème le mélange entre jeunesse et
expérience semblant en tout cas pétiller
reste à le faire exploser face aux
champions de France en titre mardi soir
en ouverture du championnat
il y a tout juste une semaine Thomas
Barouk a remporté à Amsterdam sa
première média médaille mondiale dans la
catégorie 200 barreurs un titre de vie
champion du monde glané avec la deuxième
meilleure performance mondiale de tous
les temps entretiens exclusif réalisé
avec Elodie moine et William elle
Thomas bonjour merci de nous recevoir
après cette superbe médaille d'argent au
glané au Championnat du Monde d'aviron à
Amsterdam tout d'abord première question
enfin peut-être une première médaille
mondiale effectivement c'est une
première médaille de championnat du
monde c'est pas une première médaille
mondiale ce que j'ai déjà une médaille
en Coupe du monde mais c'est une
première année au championnat du monde
donc ouais c'est on va dire la
concrétisation de tout le travail qui a
été accompli depuis maintenant cinq ans
au niveau et c'est vrai qu'elle est un
peu tardé à venir mais on l'apprécie
d'autant plus et vous l'attendiez depuis
un petit moment on le savait mais c'est
vrai que c'est peut-être aussi comme
vous le disiez la concrétisation d'un
travail de longues années cette médaille
en plus avec un coéquipier Augustin
moutarde que que vous connaissiez depuis
peu en fait oui effectivement on a
commencé à ramer ensemble dans un dans
un 200 barreur uniquement de cette année
on a commencé les premières sorties en
octobre donc ça a fait peu de kilomètres
ensemble encore moins de compétition
la finale au championnat du monde c'est
que notre dixième course ensemble
donc il nous a par moment notamment de
Michel manquer un peu de cohésion et
d'expérience ado mais en arriver déjà à
ce niveau de performance après 10
courses on est très très satisfait du
résultat justement avec ce manque
d'expérience un dix courses vous le
disiez est-ce que c'est un peu la
médaille de la surprise quand même où
vous vous attendiez à ça vous vous
faisiez ces temps un peu à
l'entraînement alors nos chronos
l'entraînement et c'est penser quand
même qu'on était très rapide c'était
vraiment très très satisfaisant et puis
surtout il y avait pas une sortie ou on
n'arrivait pas à reproduire ces vitesses
là on savait qu'on était dans les clous
maintenant on a toujours le doute
concernant nos adversaires on les avait
jamais rencontrés parce qu'on n'a pas
fait la saison internationale dans ce
bateau là
on savait qu'ils étaient forts on était
un peu sur la retenue en termes de
pronostics on savait qu'on pouvait être
dans le coup mais que on est voilà on
était pas sûr d'aller faire une médaille
en partant à Amsterdam vous finissez
deuxième derrière les Suisses qui
battent le record du monde et vous-même
tous les deux vous faites la deuxième
performance mondiale de tous les temps
donc le précédent record du monde que
vous avez battu c'est quand même déjà
exceptionnel ça c'est vrai que c'est
vraiment le signe que la performance des
deux bateaux et très bonne et pas c'est
pas un championnat du monde au rabais
alors les meilleurs temps mondiaux en
avion parce que c'est pas des records du
monde c'est des meilleurs temps mondiaux
parce que c'est vraiment très dépendant
du bassin et des conditions extérieures
donc faut pas se voiler la face tout les
records du monde enfin tous les
meilleurs temps mondiaux justement se
font sur des bassins rapides dans des
conditions favorables mais là ça a
vraiment été le cas d'un goutte à
l'autre presque d'un bout à l'autre de
toutes les finales il y a je sais plus
combien de records je suis moins une
quinzaine de meilleurs temps mondiaux
qui sont tombés ce week-end mais donc
voilà avoir nous aussi réussi à battre
le précédent alors on n'a pas le
meilleur temps mondial parce que plus
vite que nous en finale mais c'est
vraiment une grande satisfaction et il y
a un peu de frustration quand même de se
dire vous auriez pu mettre votre nom
dans l'histoire de votre discipline et
puis il y a les Suisses qui qui vous
raflent un peu la mise d'autant plus de
frustration que les conditions n'étaient
pas parfaitement équitables et que les
Suisses sont très loin de nous sur une
ligne d'oie c'est avantagée en finale
malgré ça nous on arrive à battre les
Anglais sur un finish il a pas fallu
chômer donc c'est vraiment une très très
bonne performance par rapport à cette
finale est-ce que vous pouvez nous la
raconter comment vous l'avez vécu on
fait un bon départ je crois qu'on fait
vraiment un bon départ
tous les autres bateaux cherchent à
partir aussi vite parce que c'est une
finale et qui vaut mieux la courir aux
avant-postes
on cherche pas en rajouter plus que ça
parce qu'on sait qu'on est assez rapide
sur le départ et effectivement on part
devant les autres donc on se met dans de
bonnes conditions après les Anglais font
vraiment le forcing mais encore une fois
on s'y attendait on avait regardé
comment il courait sur les autres
finales de la saison même si on n'était
pas à côté d'eux on savait qu'ils
allaient partir fort et pousser plus
loin possible donc on sait pas étonné de
les voir nous remonter et passer un peu
devant et surtout on sait pas affolé
quand dans le troisième quart de la
course justement les Suisses et les
Anglais nous décalent alors qu'on est
déjà nous en train de vraiment appuyer
pour distancer l'échecs qui sont juste à
notre gauche et qui finissent par
exploser parce que eux aussi sont dans
la même situation c'est-à-dire que un
peu des bonnes avantagés par le bassin
ils sont obligés de vraiment s'employer
pour rester au contact sur ce problème
500 fait vraiment un gros boulot pour
rester au contact de tous les autres et
distancer les checks et puis après dans
le dernier 500 jette un petit coup
d'oeil à 500 mètres de la ligne je vois
que les anglais sont pas encore trop
loin donc on lâche tout puis on essayait
d'y aller alors progressivement c'est à
dire on en met une petite couche on
gagne un ou deux grandes cadences
sur l'avant dernier 250 mètres et puis
quand on voit les bouées rouges à 250 m
de la ligne en réfléchit plus on a hâte
de regarder à côté et puis on fait en
sorte que le bateau est le plus vite
possible jusqu'au bout vous disiez
finalement pas très équitable quelle est
la raison c'est le bassin qui était pas
très homogène il y avait du vent voilà
quel était le problème le vent était pas
tout à fait dans l'axe du bassin et
avantagé les Lindos 1 2 + que les Lindos
5 6 nous on est allé une do 4 les
Suisses et les Anglais étaient une et
deux donc il y a effectivement une
partie du bassin sur laquelle ils ont
vraiment un tapis roulant dessus du
bateau et nous on est vraiment moins
avantageux on est on est moins porté par
le vent et par le courant et ça se voit
très clairement sur toutes les courses
de l'après-midi et ça s'est revu le
lendemain malheureusement pour un autre
bateau français d'ailleurs qui fait 2e à
900e par rapport à un bateau Quelle est
qu'il a battu trois secondes en
demi-finale de jour avant est-ce que
derrière évidemment il y a la volonté de
prolonger l'aventure avec lui de se dire
on va l'essayer d'aller chercher de
l'année d'autres titres derrière oui
c'est sûr je crois qu'on a vraiment
envie de continuer ensemble on a trouvé
de très bonnes choses sur ce sur ce
stage terminal avant les championnats du
monde et encore on a on a réussi à en
mettre une partie en application pendant
les courses mais on sent bien qu'on
n'est pas encore au maximum de notre
potentiel dans ce bateau là il y a
encore de la progression il y a encore
de une marge de progression et donc ça
sera intéressant d'aller la chercher et
clairement on a envie de continuer
ensemble d'aller chercher pour commencer
le titre de champion de France l'année
prochaine au mois d'avril le seul petit
x si j'ose dire c'est que ce n'est pas
une discipline olympique de son barreur
ça c'est peut-être un il y aura
peut-être un good inachevé dans ces
disciplines là
alors inachevé je sais pas parce que on
est au courant que ce que c'est pas
olympique et que c'est entre guillemets
l'antichambre du bateau olympique qui
est le 400 bars quoi léger maintenant si
on est très performant en 200 bas on a
de bonnes chances de remonter dans le
400 barrière d'ailleurs nos performances
de cette année justifier qu'on soit dans
le 400 barreur et une décision de
l'entraîneur qui a été de changer le
bateau avant les championnats du monde
mais on a quand même fait toute la
saison internationale et notamment une
médaille de bronze championnats d'Europe
tant de 400 bars dans le bateau
olympique donc voilà on sait que si on
est performant en 200 bas on finira par
monter dans le 400 et donc probablement
aller aux Jeux Olympiques
75 jours 9 heures et 25 minutes c'est le
temps que nos deux rameurs Yvelines
noires ont mis pour franchir la ligne
d'arrivée de la Great Pacifique race
2014 Christophe papillon et Clément Elio
originaire de Mimont dans les Yvelines à
bord de leur bateau la cigogne ont
réussi à rallier la California Hawaii à
la RAM s'il vous plaît soit 3900 km à
vol d'oiseau il établissent là le record
de la traversée dans leur catégorie ils
étaient évidemment comblés une fois pied
à terre mais ils ont réalisé une
traversée inoubliable au cours de
laquelle les deux jeunes ont perdu pas
moins de 7 à 9 kg en athlétisme Antonin
Keita a retrouvé le chemin de l'or
l'athlète de l'EA Saint-Quentin c'est
imposé sur le 400 mètres cet été des
championnats d'Europe d'athlétisme
handisport absente lors des derniers
championnats du monde à Lyon pour cause
de blessures la sprinteuse yvinoise a
signé un retour majuscule avec l'équipe
de France et en finale d'Antonin Keita a
même battu sa meilleure performance de
la saison en football pour le compte de
la troisième journée de une vision
d'honneur Versailles leader avant la
rencontre s'est fait accrocher à Melun
match nul 0 0 mais les Yvelines restent
tout de même invaincu et un match nul
qui a évidemment des conséquences au
classement Versailles perd son
leadership et rétrograde à la troisième
place à de longueur du leader Créteil
l'usitanos en promotion d'honneur
c'était la grande reprise ce week-end
pour cette première journée trap c'est
facilement imposé dans le derby
yvelinois sur la pelouse du Pecq 3
business grâce à cette première victoire
les Trappistes son deuxième à la
différence de but derrière Pontoise si
les championnats seniors vous l'avez vu
ont repris ce week-end dans les écoles
de foot les jeunes footballeurs sont à
l'entraînement depuis la fin août à
l'occasion du premier tournoi des
partenaires de la Joce à Élancourt nous
avons pu nous entretenir avec
Jean-Pierre Leduc président de l'OSC à
l'aube de cette saison post Coupe du
Monde qui bénéficie des bonnes
performances de l'équipe de France
par rapport à l'année dernière on a déjà
beaucoup plus inscriptions de fait dès
maintenant ça veut dire que la
garanticiper par rapport l'année
dernière et je pense que globalement on
doit avoir un surplus de licence
effectivement la Coupe du monde a joué
est-ce qu'effectivement quand l'équipe
de France se porte bien les inscriptions
se portaient bien là aussi c'est
effectivement ça s'ajout
c'est la fin de ce premier satisport de
la saison on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine mais mieux même heure
excellente soirée sur TV filles